it's great to welcome to the program
today David Brotherton who's a professor
of sociology at the City University of
New York he's extensively studied the
legalization of street gangs in Ecuador
and its possible effects on the homicide
rate which has fallen over the last
decade a David first and foremost thanks
for talking to me today oh thanks thanks
for watching ray so let's get right into
this when when people hear these
headlines Ecuador legalizing street
gangs it's often misinterpreted to mean
legalizing the illegal activities of
street gangs but that's that's not what
we're talking about at all we're
actually talking about something very
different
what did ecuador do let's start there
while they in about 2007 2008 I decided
to give major street gangs in in Ecuador
large street gangs such as Latin Kings
and Queens or the ietters which you know
these are gangs that are up here an
opportunity to become you know what they
call cultural associations to kind of
build a social movement if you like
based on their abilities to to organize
and to collectivise so they they were
allowed to become associations legal
associations and function almost as
nonprofits and you know apply for
government grants and it's on and so
forth and it was a way to kind of
decriminalize young people in in these
kind of street subcultures and to social
include them it was a national policy of
of social inclusion and it was under the
auspices of the what president correr at
that time 2007 he came to power called
the citizen's revolution and this was an
idea to make everybody a fully fledged
citizen and and bring them in you know
part of civil society and empower them
and they thought it was you know a great
idea something similar had happened in
in Spain in Barcelona and in Italy and
and they thought this would be you know
an excellent an alternative to what the
US were exporting at the time which was
a policy of zero tolerance to two gangs
in particular because what they'd seen
with that policy for example in Central
America was the opposite you know
massive increase in homicide and in
interpersonal violence and they didn't
want to go that they wanted to go
another one alternative you through a
much more progressive route and and the
outcome of ten or eleven years is
Ecuador now has the the sharpest and
most sustainable drop in homicide in the
world so in a second I want to get to
the statistics in a second but so to go
back to sort of the initial framework
here the gang organizations themselves
can become similar to what we might
consider a nonprofit organization in the
United States the individual criminal
activities that gang members might
individually participate in are of
course still criminal so what behaviors
change and what else do gang members
start participating in by virtue of this
status legalization that takes place
well you know they first one of the
first things that happens is that they
begin to work with one another you know
as in kind of solidarity if you like
with one another these are poor kids
very poor kids highly marginalized young
people many of them often indigenous and
and they've they've grown up with a
great deal of discrimination and
marginalization which is part of the
reason they're in the game and so now
you know they're being encouraged to
work with one another to end kind of
animosity and conflict work things out
so why are the first things that
happened there's a drop in interpersonal
way into gang into group conflict when
the first things happened then you see
them these young people you know become
kind of aspirational instead of thinking
that they're you know just you're always
going to be kicked out of school they're
always going to be rejected they see a
society that actually is trying to
welcome them you know the government is
saying come on you know be do your bit
as a citizen you know go to school work
you
get a job being apprentice go to
university you know we want you right
but I'm gonna we're not criminalizing
you anymore I'm not rejecting you
anymore like there's been in the past we
really want you and and so it fell you
know people think well it falls on deaf
ears
you know because gangs are you know
intrinsically antisocial or anti
educational anti this well yeah that's
if you if you stigmatize them and and
believe that's you know going to be the
truth that will be the truth you know
called a self-fulfilling prophecy but if
you give young people an opportunity a
chance a real chance not a make-believe
chance and stay with them over time this
is over so this is constant over ten
years do you build up these incredible
trust relationships and these young
people can still be members of these
gangs the gangs change the gangs become
much more pro-social much more Pro
community and the youth inside become
much more aspirational and engaging
roots of social mobility you know finish
their schooling gaussians one University
in Quito for example one one gang along
the Latin Kings has 200 members in that
one University a registered I doing
professional courses or academic course
is this incredible right over ten years
because they want it they have
scholarships and sun-soaked so things
change I mean it seems that what you're
really doing is you're drilling into the
sort of environmental causes that get
people to be attracted to gangs in the
first place and you're trying to deal
with that by changing the sort of
disconnect from broader society changing
the circumstances of sort of maybe a
feeling of hopelessness and that that
can often lead people you're really
dealing directly with that in a sense
absolutely but you know what what
happens mostly in in the West you know
and when we deal with gangs is we try to
change one at a time right in a one
individual and let you know or we
lecture them and say you don't join the
gang and and we get we engaging in kind
of policies of prevention you know and
all these kind of very moralistic
approaches it's sort of recognizing that
these groups are there you know you're
not just going to be Radek I did you
can't
some like you would a cancer you know
that and they're there for a reason and
it's it's the way these kids who grow up
and see the world so it's that so when
you work with the entire group and you
respect their choices you respect the
kind of subcultures that they're formed
and then you bring them in and and show
them how these subcultures could become
much more proactive much more creative
and you know in generative and and they
could be you know we engage the
community in community that may have
kind of rejected them and on so many
different levels I mean in our in
culture and employment in work in crime
control believe it or not all kinds of
things you mentioned already that
there's been this pretty sustained
decline in the homicide rate the murder
rate in Ecuador since this was done but
of course as I often preach to my
audience correlation and causation are
two different things
so what case is there to be made that
this was a decline caused by this
legalization of the gang entities well
it you know is again you know I wouldn't
say there's this direct you know there's
a correlation you know it's very
difficult to say well because they
joined the these groups and they formed
these associations therefore in
Guayaquil Akito the you know the rates
of homicide naturally the you know
therefore declined I mean there's a
correlation what what exactly the
relationship is you know is what you
know we're kind of standing at the
moment but so in order to study that you
know we've interviewed the leaders of
these three clubs all across in
different settings in Guayaquil in that
says Morales on the Pacific Northwest in
Quito in the end is you know all these
different settings and they say you know
similar things that they they say for
example that they rediscover the trust
if you like in the government and in
with government bureaucrats or
government policymakers or government
social workers that they didn't have
before they found another in a trust or
an engagement with edges going to
university and so on before things goals
which they
have before they found experience
themselves our jobs new opportunities
for training and social mobility they
experienced that so all of these things
took them away from if you like that
might have been a life of crime or you
know a life of violence or you know or
group into group kind of violence all
that dropped off you see so there cuz
they're doing other things with their
time and they're feeling very positive
and ambitious and looking towards the
future you know in a in a creative and
positive way as opposed to you know
there is no future
you know except my homeboys and
homegirls and and that's it you know now
there's there's it there's that they're
invested in society and society is
invested in them which is as it should
be and and so you know where does
violence come in well you know there's
no need for the violence you know that
their time we spent doing much more
proactive and positive things so also
the relationship with the police
obviously must change the police was
also reformed we shouldn't forget that
you know a lot of the kind of bad eggs
as it were the police were were purged
were gotten rid of you know police who
would head brutal past and so on and so
forth and they bought in a whole new
kind of police force which they called
the policy a communitarian if you mean
the communitarian police they changed
the training of police and made their
training much less militarized they
brought in loads of women about 30% of
the new police force of females and they
deal with people differently than the
men and so all this change - and so all
their relationships with society changed
and so you know violence is a is a
natural kind of diminishes it naturally
diminishes when people become socially
included the problem is especially the
United States and we don't do that
anymore we don't believe in social
exclusion we actually most of our
policies are based on social exclusion
you know the great example of that is
the fact that we have 25 percent of the
world's inmates and it's a failure it's
a it's a dismal failure in them if you
compare Ecuador and the United States
the amount of money we spend on Crime
Control and weaponry and militarization
and so on and so forth
is astronomical it's it's in the
trillions yes a little bit about the
toilets if we can if we can and we we
are starting to get sort of to the end
of our time we often here anytime that
there's a discussion about look at what
this other country is doing and how well
it works there is invariably some
refrain from some section of the sort of
American commentary world that what
works in whatever country would not work
in the United States so for single-payer
health care for example we hear well the
United States has more people or the
United States is more diverse in terms
of the health issues people have
whatever right does think you sort of
understand the idea with this idea
around gangs you could imagine that
people would say well it's different
because there are more gangs it's
different because the country is bigger
it's different because it's more
difficult to achieve a type of social
cohesion in a more diverse country than
Ecuador for example I'm just throwing
out ideas are there any good reasons
that a similar policy would not work in
the United States no okay is there
reason we say about why it would work in
the United States because we used to
have a policy of social inclusion you
know much of the policy in in Ecuador a
lot of it comes from you know what used
to be in the United States and the
fifties and the sixties you know in this
you know we had policies in the sixties
where where gangs were but many of the
gangs could get grants and and which we
into social movement so especially in
Chicago and and New York City
you know gangs change the young Lords
were a political movement of Puerto
Ricans the Vice Lords also were very
political I mean you know the way we
used to deal with gangs it used to be a
social problem it wasn't a crime problem
and the first people who used to reach
out to the gangs if there were issues
were social workers there were Street
social workers we got rid of all the
street social workers in the 1970s they
don't exist anymore in the United States
and we replaced them with police armed
to the teeth and gang squads and gang
task forces and God knows what else
and what you get is when you when you
try to stamp out a behavior that you
don't want
you know bit drug use for whatever you
stack you know you strut you ready Kate
it what you're actually doing you end up
prolifically helping that that behavior
to proliferate in criminology we call it
deviance amplification and that's
exactly what we've done in the United
States and that's exactly what we've
exported to the rest of the world now if
we exported social inclusion you're in a
vastly different kind of outcomes in for
example in the northern triangle in
Central America where those three
country of the highest homicide rates in
the world
or Brazil or whatever but instead they
import in the America model as if this
is the as if this is the ago exemplar in
fact it's not it's disastrous absolutely
fascinating work we've been speaking
with David Brotherton who's a professor
of sociology at the City University of
New York David really a pleasure having
you on I appreciate it thanks for having
me